well hello there you're watching the
press preview a first look at what is on
the front pages
well coming up in the next half hour
then we'll see what's making the
headlines with andrew pierce consultant
editor at the daily mail
and kevin mcguire associate editor at
the daily mirror get your thoughts in
just a moment firstly let's check out
the front pages
the daily mirror then back to school
shambles is the headline
for the mirror ahead of the return of
schools in england on the 8th of march
and it's the education secretary gavin
williamson on the daily stars front page
we did
do a whoopsie it says schools
also on the front of the guardian with
reports that teachers will get the
powers to decide exam results
in england the times leading with the
same story
schools told to work out their own exam
grades
and summer exams to be voluntary that's
also the lead for the telegraph
the government's latest stay-at-home
advert is on the front page of the
i the daily express leading on the
budget next week with a warning to the
chancellor
to not raise taxes
similar theme on the front page of the
daily mail
rishi's spring booster for the uk their
headline
for tomorrow's paper looking ahead to
next week
and mckinsey to ditch snida as head
after string of crises is the lead in
the financial times
and the metro upbeat festivals are back
they declare
as reading and leads give the green
light for this summer
so after doing this for nearly a year we
have some sound problems with kevin
mcguire would you believe you think we'd
have got it right by now so i'm left
with you for goodness sake there we are
good
lovely um anyway the breaking news i
guess
tonight uh from the papers um embargo
till a bit later to be fair
is how we're going to deal with exams
this summer what's the latest
well after the shambles of last year
anna of qual the algorithm could anybody
forget the algorithm i vaguely
remembered them from years ago studying
them at school or science
the government have gone for the obvious
clear-cut way
they're going to rely on teachers to
grade pupils they will be based on
coursework teachers assessment uh um
some some schools they have the option
of um sitting exams as well but
basically
features there's gonna the the where the
worry will be there'll be huge grade
inflation but look
my god these kids have been through hell
not being able to go to school for a
year they're not being able to sit their
exams last year they're not sitting
their exams this year
all sorts of impacts on their employment
prospects
where they want to do apprenticeship or
whether they want to get into university
so um sense has prevailed uh gavin
williamson who is probably the least
effective education secretary
in the history of education secretaries
seem to have got this one right this
time
uh uh the head teachers have welcomed it
teachers seem to have welcomed it and
i'm sure the pupils have welcomed it too
the kids have got to leave school with
something at the end of this terrible
year for them
yes great inflation an issue the bigger
issue possibly is
the divergence in results depending on
how well
you coped with lockdown and home
learning isn't it which is the real
concern
obviously yeah and also of course some
some kids will have had better or
broadband access some kids would have
had better
uh ipads and computers at my own
newspapers you know has run a very
vigorous campaign
we donated we've raised millions of
pounds to get
computers into children's homes because
often the computers weren't good enough
so
these are all factors and i think this
is why teachers who know the kids best
can make the best assessment there'll
always be somebody who will say oh but
my teacher hates my guts
that would have been a real problem for
me let me tell you anna at school
because i was always getting on the
wrong side
of my teachers but you've got to trust
the teachers
they do know best uh and the kids in it
and
it's also an incentive i think for the
children to work really really hard
between now and the end of term try and
impressively just
get those decent grades yeah but you
know for a level
students um their teachers might barely
know them i mean they've missed part of
last year part of this it's quite hard
to assess how your
you know how your pupils are doing it's
um anyway that announcement expected by
gavin williamson
uh on uh god what day is it thursday um
but he also spoke today didn't he
uh this is the daily mirror britain's
back to school shambles
and um confirmation that the secondary
schools are going to be staggered
because of the issue of testing trying
to get two tests a day
with these pupils uh so what's the
what's the daily mirror saying
well the mirror is saying uh classic
gavin williamson most schools aren't
prepared
but part of this the test is it's all to
do with the testing of the covid testing
because they want the kids to have
tests every day or before they go to
school
they said that schools have got to be
equipped to do the testing
people got to show the staff how to do
the testing parents have to learn
how to do the testing it's going to be
very difficult but
you know i still say this they've got to
go for bro
there was a suggestion in the guardian i
think a week or two ago that um the
chief medical officer uh
chris whittie was against the big bang
approach to all schools going back he
emphatically denied that in that
briefing this week and said it is
absolutely vital
for the mental health of children for
their well-being for the future
health of the economy that we get these
kids back to school as soon as possible
so
let's go for march the eighth of course
there's going to be some problems of
course there's going to be some issues
but the bet that it's much better that
they're trying to get the kids back to
school than the shambles we had
after the christmas term when they went
back to school for one day that was
awful
look what you've done to your friend and
adversary or is it just that he's
waiting patiently it might just be
because you talked so much but anyway
he's falling asleep he's read one of his
stories
he's so boring oh i don't need
slipping pills
you missed quite a lot but anyway we
were talking about secondary schools
going back
um this idea of the big bang everyone
back in one go
you know whether the you know they're
all going back in on the week of
the eighth of march probably because of
testing where do you stand on this
on the battle that unions had which was
really that it's not necessarily safe
that everybody goes back at once
what's your thoughts on that kevin yeah
i thought the government when it started
suggesting it would be all schools in
england on the on the 8th of march
monday the 8th of march a week monday
was wrong it's now been changed to all
primary schools on the monday and then
secondaries will be
phased but it is it's got to be a top
priority to try and get schools back but
you've got you've got to discuss with
teachers
heads with their representatives trade
unions to try and do it as safely as
possible and of course the government
had a golden opportunity
to answer many of the concerns by
vaccinating
teachers you could probably do them all
in just about a day now but they but
they haven't
but schools are going to go back and not
going to go quite back the way
they said they would go um because it
will be phased over that week and some
of them may not fully open but
kids have been going certainly from from
key workers and vulnerable kids have
been going
uh continually so schools have been open
it's just been open for more limited
numbers
um but those kids falling behind we saw
the studies
released today and it's particularly
kids from poorer families who are
falling further behind and they may
never be able to catch up
governments come up with a scheme but it
seems to be spending less money on
catching up for kids than it is on stamp
duty cuts for
for house buyers great news for uh house
buyers but not great news
for kids so get them back as soon as
they can but you've got to address the
concerns of teachers
you can't just steamroll it through yes
we'll do the budget uh in the next part
of our program
um which of you hip and happening young
men want to talk about festivals front
page of the metro
yeah kevin's an old hippie he probably
he's probably going to go to the reading
festival
because lots of women take their clothes
off so he'll be very excited by that
i think i think i think reading and
leads tend to be a bit of a younger
crowd than us uh andrew we'd be paying
you in mate
yeah we'd be more latitude i think in
there
don't drag me into it i never go to
festivals well
you know you could get a job on the
gates checking tickets over the floor
yeah like that'll get you get you in the
bar or cleaning the toilets that's
probably here
i want to make a blind ball bring back
blind ball
it is a sign of how the public mood
has changed since monday and we saw it
with holidays being booked
now festivals are coming back it's not
just leads and running it looks like
melbourne uh ben one of the organisms
saying latitude wireless download might
come up in manchester sasha lord will
say park life and the warehouse project
all these are vessels that people want
to go to they haven't been able to
to get there vaccination is changing the
game
possibly linked to to tests but there is
a feel-good factor now
but kevin there's a sense of a row back
too isn't that if you look at the eye
the government's released this this
campaign about staying home
we've been filming in warrington
hospital for the last two days they're
really worried about the numbers of
people now coming through the door with
ordinary winter pressures as well as
coved so this is this is the figures are
still high it's already gone
yep i think this is a
well the government's hoping it's a
short term
problem until you get more people
vaccinated
and you you basically get the
get the numbers further down so we can
see them falling all the time
and the problem i think um the prime
minister has now
he talks about to one-way one-way road
is irreversible of course it's not a
one-way road it's not irreversible if
numbers saw and he'd be in
serious trouble now because expectations
have been
raised so so highly because people have
a fatigue really they want to get out
they want to do the things that
they used to do yeah
the measures but people want to break
free too andrew
i just think that the eye story feels
slightly out of kilter really because
the deputy chief medical officer today
i've forgotten her name jenny
jenny yes yeah she was saying actually
in the summer we may not even have to
wear masks
but she was saying they'll be back in
the winter so and she
and there has been that's there was a
suggestion last week that actually
we could have gone on the beaches last
summer because the infection rate is so
much
more limited outdoors we're always being
told
you know if you're indoors get the
windows open uh uh okay
have have houses um you know get keep
doors open so
actually being in the great outdoors i
think it's to be all right actually
okay of course they've got to keep an
eye on it we've got to have some program
left at the other end
we'll have to take a break now they
could talk all night can they um plenty
more still to come we'll talk about the
budget
how the papers are covering that
welcome back you're watching the press
review with me now andrew and kevin as
usual on a wednesday
um straight to the daily mail your paper
andrew looking ahead to the budget
a tight rope for the chancellor needs
money in but how and when does he take
it
well what the mail is saying and we
would i i personally
i'm thrilled that it's not going to
raise taxes of course he's got to get
money in but i mean i've always taken
the view the more you tax people the
less revenue the exchequer gets so
the stamp duty holiday that was due to
end on march the 1st or march the 5th
end of march i think that's going to be
extended till the end of june probably
now that's really important it will cost
them revenue in terms of
money going into the treasury but it
will be a huge boost for the housing
market people invest in new bathrooms
kitchen sinks all the rest of it
let's talk about a cutting va2 for the
hospitality industry
yes they need it desperately keep the
business rates
cuts going and also talk about vouchers
to encourage people to go into the high
street and here's one other thing i
think you should do
one tax rise you should bring in not
corporation tax
don't do that don't tax companies
profits bring in a tax
on the tech giants like amazon uh who
don't appear to
know how to pay any tax the way all the
rest of us do
that would be very popular mooted for a
long time obviously and what about
kirsten's position certainly on taxes
for business what's
uh what's he said and what's the
reaction likely to be
yeah what he said is the government
shouldn't increase corporation tax it
was in the labor manifesto to increase
corporation taxes they now don't do it
thought the treasury's thinking of
putting up it's gone down from i think
to 19 since the conservatives came into
power putting it back to 23 or 25
23 would raise about 12 million pounds
and of course stoma's getting
a bit in the net on this now a short
term i could i could see his argument
but this is about corporation tax you
only pay
if you've got profit so if you've got no
profits you won't you won't pay it so if
firms are being hit hard in the pandemic
they won't pay it
so he's uh he's got a bit of a limb here
of course he wants to be friendly with
business
but you know corporation tax it's it's
also dangerous for the government i
think putting it back because he always
argued the lower it came the more money
the treasury would make now they're
going completely against that
if the chancellor puts it up he's also
uh killing his former argument
okay we will watch and wait uh plenty
more column interest to be written about
that no doubt uh before the uh budget
next week
see at 11 thank you to the weather now